[Music]
so teach what are the test results Teddy
you my friend are dyslexic
you also have dyscalculia that's what I
got we're not done you also have a
processing disorder I got a touch of
prostate cancer she didn't touch my ass
one time boy welcome to night school
we need to cramp four years of high
school into a semester I think here's
mama breastfed him being the
conventional way just isn't gonna get it
done Bobby in wait what's the square
root of 81 what this woman is a brick
wall you either pass the midterm or you
out of my class when I'm still tested
you want to explain to me how you got a
perfect score
I know I didn't get a perfect score
because I missed a few on purpose
snitches are [ __ ] what I'm going to
work I'm gonna get you chicken from the
Lord Teddy this suit you got on its
dermis hey I'm where I'm supposed to be
at a fast food point next to a strip
club rusty in the right spot I could
smell cocoa butter and fried chicken at
the same time you can get on my way
[ __ ]
[Music]
ready to get started I'm not playing
with you it's the capital Belgian
waffles you starting to force my hand
water is comprised of rain you got it
right Eddie where's that smell now
that's a gas you bust ass in my face
it's in my mouth
[Music]